Now I am sure you have seen in the latest wave of PSA's imploring you
not to eat a Tide pod
Well I'm not here to tell you not to eat a Tide pod
I'm just gonna tell what to expect if you try...
You see the pods outer layer is a plastic wrapping that puts its contents under pressure
so you don't have too bite all that hard for the gel inside to explode out
If the gel does indeed come into contact with the insides of your mouth
which is kinda the point in all this...
its low PH levels will begin killing any cells
it comes into contact with immediately
And when cells die they don't just VANISH
they leave behind their remains...leaving your mouth filled with dead cells
and damaged tissue
as the gel causes an immediate burning sensation.
A burning sensation that will be AGONIZINGLY painful!
The gel of the pod is thick, and because of how thick and sticky it is
if some of it goes down your throat, it can become stuck or lodged
in your esophagus, killing even more cells as it goes.
This, in turn, will kick your immune system in high gear
resulting in swelling.
That swelling of your esophagus can also affect the
muscles that control your breathing.
Meaning you just might find yourself choking
even if you do manage to vomit up the detergent.
If you managed to survive the Tide Pod challenge by not choking to death
Congratulations! You now get the joy of spending
several days with the lingering pain of chemical burns
inside of your body.
Now for those of you who fancy yourselves
hardcore enough for a REAL challenge
I've got two words for ya.
Chubby
Bunny.
*intro*
*Trigger Warning - this episode contains mentions of suicide*
Hello internet! Welcome to Film Theory!
Where today we're talking about dumb news.
And by dumb news, I don't mean people chomping
on Tide Pods,
I'm talking about the media that gobbled
up this story faster than an unattended 6 year old
with brightly colored detergent packets.
As the story goes, sometime in late December 2017
Several viral tweets brought up the idea of eating Tide Pods like candy.
The biggest being this thread with everyone's favorite
lunchtime snack Gushers, trying to get them make a Tide Pod themed flavor
Now, this was far from the first time the idea of
detergent packet equals candy was brought up
But it was the first time that people actually took it seriously.
Causing a supposed epidemic sweeping through the internet as kids across the country
started filming themselves cramming laundry detergent
into their mouths. The internet began mocking the trend
in its usual fashion,  numerous businesses moved
to cash in, YouTube and Facebook began banning
Tidepod videos, and Tide released what turned out to be
one of the most baffling PSAs of all time.
And, of course, there was requisite mainstream media coverage
wagging their fingers at teenagers across the country, saying
"Can you believe kids these days?" or
"Oh, these stupid teenagers trying to find viral fame!"
Except they're completely wrong to blame the teenagers.
This time, mainstream media is the one to blame.
If you stop and look at the data,
it becomes clear that the story of this dangerous new trend online
was something that THEY created.
They took a small handful of jokes and videos, and blew
it up into a fad that suddenly had
thousands of copycats.
So don't be wagging your finger at "kids these days", news media!
You're the problem this time.
And good ol' MatPat is about to show you why.
A January 22nd press release from the American Association of Poison Control Center (AAPCC),
reported that between January 1st
and January 14th,
they received a total of 39 cases of teens intentionally exposing themselves to a liquid laundry packet
39 cases in 14 days.
The following week, there were an additional 47 calls
In other words, we see a huge spike of the number
of Poisoning Control Center calls relating
to teens ingesting Tide Pod after January 14th.
Now, remember that day
because it's not just an increasing calls after January 14
it's also in increase in videos.
As I mentioned before,
most people claim that teens started munching on Tide Pod packets
in late December and through early January.
But if you actually look at the numbers,
that just isn't true.
From December 1 through January 7,
There's only 242 Tide Pod videos
across all of Twitter, Instagram, YouTube and Facebook.
Yeah, I checked them all.
Now, that may seem like a lot,
but look at this:
Between the 7th and 14th,
there were 387 more.
In one week, as opposed to 5 weeks.
But, here's where the things start to get crazy.
Between the 14th and the 21st,
1,502 new Tide Pod videos
get uploaded
In just 7 days!
Then next week, another 1,517 new videos.
So anyway you look at the data,
it seems like between the 13th and 14th,
something happened that caused the sudden spike
in Tide Pod related incidents.
This period here, is when the trend
blew up.
Now, you might think it was online influencers
talking about the trend that spread awareness of the problem,
But that's...
not definitely not the case here.
The top Tide Pod video online belongs to the meme lord
"CAN YOUR CHAIR DO THIS?"
PewDiePie
whose video on the subject was released January 4th
Racking up most of its 6 MILLION views
in a matter of 5 days.
If he were truly the one driving more videos to be made,
you would see an uptake in the aftermath of his video.
But what you actually see
is the EXACT OPPOSITE.
Looking at Tide Pod video uploads,
day by day, the trend was practically dead
around the 9th and 10th
having only around 20 videos uploaded each of these days
the lowest point that they had been for months.
which means that for the first time ever! the media CAN'T
blame something on ya boii Pewds
Truth be told
most of the internet was kinda over Tide pods by that point...
Nope!
This the news is gonna point the finger of blame at anyone,
it has to be at THEMSELVES.
January 12th is when Tide released their "No, No, No, No, No" PSA.
The next day is when news organizations really started to pick up on this story,
prompting Google searches for 'Tide pod challenge' to hit an all time high.
Increasing to 10x the amount of search traffic
relative to the previous week.
And it's here when we see the uploads of videos labeled with 'Tide Pod' start to skyrocket.
Reaching between 100 and 300 new uploads every. single. day.
nearly 10x more uploads per day than when this "epidemic" was supposedly
so bad earlier in the month.
The news media had created a mountain out of a molehill,
sparked hundreds of copy-cats,
and thus the dumbest and potentially most dangerous meme of 2018,
Now let me be clear,
I don't think that they any of this intentionally,
Truth be told, they're just not smart enough.
For instance, after tide pods became a fad, a number of appeared posts on social media.
people photographing stores with anti-theft measures in place for the detergent.
People in the media found those posts and figured "Hey, it must be because of that crazy new challenge."
Except that there is a problem with those stories.
Retailers like Walmart and Kroger have been keeping products locked up to prevent theft for years!
With news stories dating all the was back to 2012 reporting that laundry detergent is one of the markets' most shop lifted items
But hey, why bother to check the facts when we have these viral tweets to go off of.
Surely these are 100% factually accurate!  The story writes itself.
Basically, what I'm trying to say here is that, in their coverage of this meme, the news created a huge case of "copycat effect."
According to David Phillips, a sociologist at the University of California at San Diego, the copycat effect goes as follows:
"When I am waiting at a traffic light, and the light is red, I wonder sometimes if I should just cross and J-Walk."
"Then someone else does it, and so I do it too. I'm getting permission to act from someone else who is engaging in a deviant act."
In other words, watching other people engage in certain behaviors makes it more acceptable for us to engage in those same activities.
*Cough*  Logan Paul *Cough*  Ugh, excuse me.
But in the case of tide pods, the sophisticated internet users knew that it was mostly meant as a joke.
But, once it hit mainstream media, those people just started to do it because they thought it was real.
**TRIGGER WARNING - suicide mentions until 8:34**
In fact, one area of heavy research right now
has featured sociologists looking into
how reporting teen suicides
actually causes suicide rates to increase. This applies locally as well as on the national level.
When Marilyn Monroe's suicide was widely reported on, the national suicide rate increased by 12%.
Because of this, many news organizations have policies in place against reporting teen suicides in obituaries.
In the process, these news organizations are acknowledging
that they have an ethical responsibility to protect the welfare of the public.
Which kinda goes against what we are going to talk about next: How they choose their stories.
Because all of this begs the question: Just how widespread of an epidemic was the Tide pod nonsense?
Earlier I had mentioned 86 total cases cited by poison control, which at first glance, seems like a lot.
But to steal a line from PewDiePie, context matters!
Poison control centers across the U.S. receive MILLIONS of calls every single year.
In 2016 alone, American poison control centers received 46,306 from parents concerned that
their kid had consumed too many vitamins?!
If 86 people eating a Tide Pod and calling poison control is cause for a news frenzy lasting for weeks,
then where the heck's the news story about the 46,306 kids chomping down on too many Flintstone's Chewables?!
Just looking at the numbers,
telling parents not to let their kids eat too many vitamins may seem like it would be the much more useful PSA
than having Gronk tell us:
[Gronk]: Use Tide Pods for washing, not eating.
[MatPat]: Well, as it turns out, the fact that Tide Pod ingestion is so statistically insignificant
is actually a huge contributor to how it became such a big story.
Research has shown that people respond most to news if it reports stories that are unique.
Which actually makes sense when you stop and think about it, right?
The word 'new' is even in the name 'news'
This is why a crazy, murderous clown roaming through the woods is likely to make national headlines,
while deaths caused by traffic accidents just don't.
In terms of actual danger to you, traffic accidents are a much bigger threat, but they just aren't newsworthy.
They're an accepted part of everyday life.
Because people react to news stories based on novelty,
the actual prevalence of the issue, like Tide Pod poisoning, doesn't actually matter.
In fact, the more common it is, the less likely it's going to get reported on!
That's why tens of thousands of vitamin overdoses get ignored,
while a handful of Tide Pod challenges are your top story for weeks.
What's more, people are more likely to respond to news stories based on how threatening they sound.
Research has shown that stories about non-threatening topics just don't get the
same kind of emotional response as stories informing people about *nasally voice* threats to their safety!
*normal voice* This is why reporting always slants negative.
Reporting on weird dangers of the modern world is the most reliable way to keep an audience engaged.
And what's weirder and more scary sounding to traditional media than
trends that teenagers are engaging with on social media?
Conveniently leave out the part that shows that the number of people
actually engaging in this behavior is minuscule,
and you've got yourself a viral news story and
a nation overreacting to something that wasn't really a big deal in the first place.
And all us people who understand how to use the internet and internet culture suffer as a result.
This whole Tide Pod story, as dumb as it is, serves as an important reminder that now, more than ever,
media seems to be concerned, not with keeping us informed, but instead with keeping us engaged.
While it's absolutely fun to laugh at all the memes,
most of us missed out on the real story here.
That this whole threat was basically a manufactured craze that, even at the height of it's popularity,
was barely even noticeable in terms of the total number of people it was actually affecting.
It also serves as a good reminder that directly lying to us isn't the only way for news to mislead us.
It's actually possible for the media to tell stories that are 'technically, factually true',
while also giving us an inaccurate view of what's really going on in the world around us.
The biggest bias in media isn't HOW stories are told, but WHICH stories are told.
For the last three years, I've been honored to partner with Bill and Melinda Gates to talk about their Annual Letter;
and this year's touches on these exact ideas.
If you listen to the headlines shouted on twitter or the stats tossed around on newspapers,
it seems like the world is in a terrible state.
"'Unconscionable': 7,000 babies die daily"
But if you read a bit deeper into the facts, what do you see?
"despite record low for child mortality".
The number of children who die every year has been cut literally IN HALF!
But that's not the fact that's making headlines here. It's not threatening enough.
"Global poverty is declining but not fast enough"
Not fast enough, you say?
In just 20 years, humanitarian efforts have been able to decrease it by 50%!
How much faster do you want us to go? We're talking about the whole world here!
"By age 3, inequality is clear: Rich kids attend school. Poor kids stay with a grandparent".
Except, you left out the fact that more children are attending school now than ever before.
In fact, people perceive things to be getting worse, even at the same time that they're actually becoming better!
For instance, this graph shows that the number of plane crashes has decreased over the last 25 year period,
but media coverage of plane crashes has increased in that same span of time.
Yes, there is always room for improvement, and sure, we all wish that change would happen faster,
but it's important to remember that we live in an incredible time.
A time for optimism.
A time where good people are out there every single day working to make a positive difference in the lives of others.
I mean, the snow leopard is no longer endangered!
Honeybee populations are on the rise for, like, the first time ever!
Child labor is down 50% since the year 2000.
HIV/AIDS is no longer the leading cause of death in Africa.
And get this! A cancer vaccine has been proven effective in mice, and has now moved on to human testing!
I mean seriously! I couldn't believe this stuff either, but these are the true facts that don't get reported on every day.
So click the link below to read Bill and Melinda Gate's letter and get a dose of positivity for a change.
It's a rare feeling these days, online;
but reading their letter was an incredible reminder that
hard work and love for your fellow man truly can make a difference.
Because in the end, the scariest news of them all is that
these positive stories are the ones that don't get reported.
BUT HEY, THAT'S JUST A THEORY!
[Person]: No. Tada.
[MatPat]: And CUT!